hey guys what's up welcome back to
cooking with Justine we're here in the
kitchen ready to cook something that was
suggested by one of you guys on Twitter
I saw this pop-up in my timeline and I
about lost my mind and I could not run
to the store vast enough to get the
ingredients so I drove there we're
making Oreo stuffed chocolate chip
cookies I mean that's basically what
dreams are made of
so let's get started butter and sugars
one two that's a cup that's a half cup I
don't know
there we go we'll just throw this in
just for good measure at bad news that's
like that's boiling butter oiling butter
you dumb idiot inseparable mix the flour
salt ha ha we're not doing any of that
mix you up a little bit for in our
butter should be faster
you slower salt
egg egg 1 tbsp vanilla extract that's
good enough 1 teaspoon baking soda and I
have baking soda
get in there so I already opened these
and started eating them it says to use a
whole bag so I'm basically just gonna
use whatever's left over over what I
didn't eat let's taste it nice taste I
feel like I forgot to boil mmm place on
a parchment or slimed baking sheet now
let's throw this up I want the city
perfect if I take an Oreo I take some
chocolate chip cookie dough so I put the
Oreo inside there put another one on top
of it oh that's great
and you just kind of mold it around it
that's really big let's put these in the
oven
Alexa set a timer for ten minutes the
cookies already
holy-moly
these are massive this is like a
mountain of I don't even know I gotta
let these cool off before I can take
them off of the pan so hold up here they
are I wanted to get a nice zoomed in
shot so you guys can see what we're
working with they're pretty much cooled
off that doesn't look like it's cooked
all the way through I wanna taste it not
cooked at all
so I recommend if you do make these make
them a little bit smaller cook them a
little bit longer and still taste good
though thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
these are actually pretty tasty I'm not
gonna lie well let me know what you guys
would like to see me cook next or
attempt to cook hope you guys enjoyed
this video I'll see you in the next one
yeah I'm gonna just put these in a
container and save them for my friends
don't tell them that they're not cooked
all the way this is heavy this is about
2 pounds of cookie see you later